we'll fair payments when people hear
that most of us think about poor people
lined up for food stamps and rent
subsidies but America's biggest welfare
recipients are politically connected
corporations like America's sugar
industry this small group of rich men
gets billions of dollars in taxpayer
subsidies and yet they have the nerve to
run ads saying we don't American farmers
don't get subsidy checks and America's
multi-billion dollar sugar program it
costs taxpayers nothing nothing
there's spokesmen going TV to say we are
a no-cost program no cost of the
taxpayer that's absolutely bogus
taxpayers do you pay the cause
Ross smart Randa the taxpayer protection
Alliance points out that sugar producers
get bailouts by US taxpayers whenever
sugar prices fall below a certain level
the government will buy sugar from the
sugar processors and then sell it to
ethanol producers at a below market rate
and who's paying the difference who's
footing the bill US taxpayers I wanted
to interview representatives of big
sugar about their sweet deal but they
wouldn't talk to me
so I'll present their deceptive
arguments from their ads and public
statements depending on others for food
never works out is expected big sugar
has the nerve to use images from World
War two to suggest we'll have food
shortages if government doesn't give
them a special deal those America really
want to give foreign countries control
over its food oh please imports increase
our supply of food there are no import
restrictions on most other foods and we
have ample supplies of them big sugar
also says American farmers don't get
subsidy checks
they get loans that are repaid with
interest has to be repaid with interest
repeat him what sugar they actually are
allowed to repay in sugar if prices fall
and taxpayers must pay the difference
but sugar prices rarely do fall because
America imposes quotas on domestic
production and limits how much sugar we
can import these are stalin style price
controls and supply controls and it does
not help anyone well it helps big sugar
the politically connected owners of the
sugar companies collect several billion
extra dollars from you roughly three
billion a year Creighton University
economist Diana Thomas explains why
Congress never repeals the sugar
industry scam the multi-billion dollar
handout costs each of us maybe ten or
twenty dollars we're not gonna go to
Washington to lobby against that but
each American sugar farmer made roughly
three million dollars a year extra so
each of them is willing to spend a lot
of time and money making sure the last
day is that way in addition Americans
must pay billions more for food because
Congress restricts imports of Cheaper
sugar from places like Brazil and India
I am prepared to get rid of the sugar
program tomorrow if the countries we
compete against get rid of there's big
sugars politicians say since other
countries foolishly subsidized sugar
we must retaliate it basically allows
our sugar industry to compete with other
countries that are heavily subsidized
it's only fair to our sugar producers
who don't get subsidized who can't
compete with these subsidized countries
is it fair for customers to pay double
the world rate for sugar is it fair for
taxpayers have to bail out a handful of
super rich super connected sugar
processors No
so crony capitalists host sweet benefit
dinners well all of us pay more
the Americans least likely to smile our
candy makers they're the ones hurt most
there's one candy cane producer left in
Ohio that's absolutely ridiculous and
look at all those jobs 20,000 jobs a
year law says this study well Big Sugar
pays for ads that say sugar has nothing
to hide that's because it's all-natural
these products they are bad for us maybe
it's good we eat less because they cost
more
well not all sugar products look like
that I mean just look at bread bread and
beer yogurt ketchup theory the fact that
sugars and everything means that healthy
and unhealthy products alike are going
to cost more and all that money is going
to that handful of rich
politically-connected
growers and processors so every time you
buy anything made of sugar you're
getting ripped off by a clever group of
businessmen who got your politicians to
pass special laws for sugar I wish more
of you went to Washington DC with a
message for big sugar and big government
get out of my life